Hi guys :D
I'm finally back from New York and that means that I can get back into the swing of things and living my own life
Except for the fact that I can't see I'm facing a dilemma either I spend the next week signing
35,000
Calendars with pictures of myself in them that are completely butt-naked or I can delete my channel run away to Bermuda crush
My phone delete all my social media and live out my life as a hermit
Because I will never have to fulfill my promise that I kept and I told you guys said I would do or
I could spend the next like two three months of my life
Signing for an hour two hours a day to try to chip away at the 35,000
So I'm gonna choose to do it all at once which means
unfortunately that I have to take a bit of a break and by a
Bit of a break means I have to work my ass off work work this hand off for 12 hours a day
Over the next week to sign
35,000
Calendars, so I'm gonna do exactly that and I don't know exactly how long it's gonna take
But I'm just letting you guys know this that as soon as I got back
I was gonna start signing because I'm ready to do it and it's all in a warehouse and I have to go to the warehouse
And live in a warehouse for the next few days
That's what I'm gonna do, so thank you everybody so much for watching, and thank you everybody so much for buying these calendars
I have no regrets about doing this campaign
I have no regrets about selling these calendars for charity because it raised over half a million dollars for the Cancer Research Institute
But I do have some regrets about having to sign
35,000 calendars with me
Naked on them, but at least they'll get to you sooner, so that's what's important. So thank you everybody for understanding
I will probably be streaming, posting pictures while I'm signing it and
Doing horrible maddening things because obviously I will have lost my sanity
Halfway through that and I won't be able to finish this with my mind intact so look forward to some funny stuff when I lose
My Mind
That'll be great alright. Thank you everybody for watching and as always. I'll see you in the next video
Buh Bye! Ehhh